at about 748 p.m. at least two suspects
entered the property from the side of
the house they came through an locked
gate they walked into the backyard and
began immediately firing into the crowd
there were approximately 16 male adults
in the backyard watching football the
witnesses described only seen flashes of
light from from the weapon as it was too
dark on that side of the house to see
see the suspects 10 of those 16 people
at that event we're hit struck by
bullets the unknown suspects fled the
scene on foot what I can't tell you is
this was not a random act it appears
that this incident was a targeted act of
violence against this residence we are
investigating leads and we do have
information that possibly some people at
this party were involved in a
disturbance earlier this week the
deceased the ages of the deceased all of
whom are residents of Fresno except for
one hour 23 year old male adult a 31
year old male adult a 38 year old male
adult and a 40 year old male adult who
died at the hospital the surviving
victims ranging in age from 28 years to
36 years old fortunately there were
children at this party and all over them
were in the house at the time of the
incident the house was not struck and it
does not appear that they were the
intended target